LARRY ELDER.
>> IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
>> Tucker: IT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE.
I AGREE.
>> MY PLEASURE.
>> Tucker: IN PUBLIC BARACK
OBAMA STAYED OUT OF THE 2020
RACE BEHIND THE SCENES IS HE
DOING THE BEST TO SHAPE HIS
PARTY.
ACCORDING TO A NEW REPORT
OBAMA HAS PROMISED OTHER
DEMOCRAT VOTERS IF BERNIE
SANDERS BEGINS TO RUN AWAY
WITH THE NOMINATION, OBAMA
WILL GET OUT THERE IN PUBLIC
AND TRY TO SABOTAGE HIS
CAMPAIGN.
BUT OBAMA ALSO ISN'T WILLING
TO SUPPORT HIS OLD RUNNING
MATE JOBE.
HE HAS REFUSED TO ENDORSE
JOE BIDEN.
HE SAID BIDEN LACKS ANY BOND
WITH IOWA VOTERS.
SO, WHO EXACTLY IS BARACK
OBAMA FOR?
WHAT'S REALLY GOING ON HERE?
DANA PERINO, HOST OF THE
DAILY BRIEFING WITH DANA
PERINO AND SHE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
>> Dana: GREAT TO BE IN
PERSON.
>> Tucker: IT IS SO NICE TO
BE HERE IN YOUR CITY OF
8 MILLION.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Tucker: LET'S GO THROUGH
THE LIST.
OBAMA APPARENTLY IS NOT FOR
BERNIE SANDERS TO THE POINT
WHERE HE WILL ACTUALLY STEP
OUT AND TRY SABOTAGE HIM.
WE KNOW THAT HE IS NOT FOR
BIDEN BECAUSE HE HASN'T
ENDORSED HIM.
>> Dana: WE ALSO KNEW THAT
IN 2016.
>> Tucker: WE ALSO KNEW THAT
EXACTLY RIGHT.
WE ALSO KNEW, I THINK TO A
CERTAINTY, THAT HE DOESN'T
LIKE ELIZABETH WARREN.
THAT'S WELL-KNOWN IN
WASHINGTON.
WHO DOES HE LIKE?
WHO IS HE FOR?
>> THAT REMAINS TO BE SEEN.
SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
FORMER PRESIDENTS TRY TO DO
IS TO STAY OUT OF THE
LIMELIGHT.
>> Tucker: YES.
>> YOU HAVE TO BE
DISCIPLINED IF YOU ARE GOING
TO DO IT.
YOU CAN'T DIP YOUR TOE IN
EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE AND
TRY TO MANEUVER THINGS FROM
MIND THE SCENES.
ALSO, ANYBODY WHO IS TALKING
TO PRESIDENT OBAMA, THEY
HAVE -- YOU FEEL
SELF-IMPORTANT.
SO THEN YOU ARE GOING TO
CALL POLITICO OR CALL OTHER
REPORTERS AND TELL THEM I
TALK TO PRESIDENT OBAMA AND
HE SAID THIS.
DON'T WORRY, HE CAN SAVE US.
BUT HE CAN'T.
HE HAS WON OPPORTUNITY TO BE
A KING MAKE ERR, RIGHT, AT
THE CONVENTION OR A
PEACEMAKER.
IF THERE IS A CONTESTED
QUNGS.
ONLY ONE OPPORTUNITY.
IF HE BLOWS IT NOW, IT'S A
LITTLE BIT TOO EARLY.
I THINK IT'S PRETTY CLEAR
THAT BIDEN DOESN'T HAVE WHAT
IT TAKES IN IOWA.
LET'S LOOK AT THE POLLS.
IT'S NOT HAPPENING.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> IT'S INTERESTING THAT
WE'RE AT THIS POINT.
LESS THAN THREE MONTHS
BEFORE THE FIRST VOTES IN
IOWA.
AND THERE ARE STILL NEW
DEMOCRATS GETTING INTO THE
RACE.
>> Tucker: YES.
>> THEY DON'T HAVE -- THEY
CAN'T PULL AS A COALITION
TOGETHER.
FROM OLDER PEOPLE TO YOUNGER
PEOPLE, TO AFRICAN-AMERICANS
AND HISPANICS, WHITE
LIBERALS, ACADEMICS, CLIMATE
CHANGE PEOPLE, THEY HAVE ALL
THESE DIFFERENT FACTIONS.
AND THAT'S BECAUSE THEY HAVE
CREATED THEM.
>> Tucker: YES.
>> THERE IS NO ONE RIGHT NOW
THAT CAN PULL THEM ALL
TOGETHER.
THE ONLY PERSON THAT THINKS
THEY CAN DO THAT IS THE
PERSON WHO WON NATIONALLY
TWICE, BARACK OBAMA.
>> Tucker: LET ME ASK YOU.
IS THIS RESOLVABLE?
I AGREE WITH YOUR ASSESSMENT
COMPLETELY.
THIS IS A RESOLVABLE
PROBLEM.
IS THERE ANY CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE FIELD OF
CANDIDATES ANYONE WHO WOULD
IN OUR IMAGINATIONS EVEN
BRING THIS COALITION
TOGETHER?
>> WELL, I THINK -- WHEN I
SAY THAT BARACK OBAMA COULD
BE A KINGMAKER OR A
PEACEMAKER, BEING A
KINGMAKER MEANS THAT YOU CAN
SAY ALL RIGHT, IN MY
OPINION, BARACK OBAMA, THIS
IS THE PERSON WHO CAN PULL
EVERYBODY TOGETHER AND YOU
TRY DRIVE THAT.
BUT I DON'T KNOW.
THERE IS GOING TO BE A LOT
OF RESENTMENT IN THE BERNIE
SANDERS WING OF THE PARTY,
IT'S HEALTHY, IT'S VIBRANT.
THEY HAVE STUCK WITH BERNIE
SANDERS.
THEY WILL BE VERY MAD.
OH, BARACK OBAMA IS SAYING
THIS?
THEY'RE THE SAME DEMOCRATS
WHO RIGGED THE THING AGAINST
ME IN 2016.
>> Tucker: SURE.
OBAMA SPENT THE LAST THREE
YEARS MAKING AMERICA BETTER?
NO.
GETTING RICH BY TALKING TO
INVESTMENT BANKERS AND HEDGE
FUND MOBILES.
NETFLIX.
HE HAS NOTHING IN COMMON
WITH, I WOULD SAY THE BERNIE
SANDERS --
>> HE DOES KNOW HOW TO WIN
TWO NATIONAL ELECTIONS.
THAT MEANS SOMETHING.
HILLARY CLINTON DIDN'T
LISTEN TO HIM.
OBAMA PEOPLE WERE SAYING YOU
HAVE TO GO TO WISCONSIN.
YOU HAVE TO DO THESE THINGS.
SHE DIDN'T DO THOSE THINGS
BECAUSE SHE KNEW BETTER.
>> Tucker: I KNOW YOU ARE
DEEPLY SKEPTICAL OF MY
BRILLIANT, AND TRUE, THEORY
ABOUT MICHELLE OBAMA COMING
IN AT THE LAST MINUTE.
TELL ME WHY?
>> BECAUSE I'M RIGHT.
I'M 100 PERCENT RIGHT.
I WANT YOU TO GO HOME AND
ASK YOUR WIFE.
IS DANA PERINO RIGHT?
AND SHE WILL SAY YES.
OKAY.
MICHELLE OBAMA SHE DOES NOT
WANT TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
SHE HAS -- SHE IS LIVING HER
BEST LIFE.
>> Tucker: YES.
>> THE DEMOCRATS ARE STILL
THINKING WOW, WE NEED A
SAVIOR TO COME IN?
EVEN IF THAT SAVIOR NEEDS TO
COME IN, IT'S NOT GOING TO
BE MICHELLE OBAMA.
SEVERAL MONTHS AGO I BET YOU
A MONTH'S SALARY TO THE
CHARITY OF OUR CHOICE, THAT
MICHELLE OBAMA WILL NEVER BE
A DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE FOR
PRESIDENT.
YOU LOOK VERY HEART-BROKEN
BY THAT.
>> Tucker: I CERTAINLY DON'T
FAVOR HER ENTRY INTO THE
RACE.
I THINK SHE CAN WIN.
>> LET ME TELL YOU ONE OTHER
THING SHE IS VERY POPULAR
RIGHT NOW.
THE MOMENT SHE TALKS ABOUT
POLICY OR POLITICS IT WOULD
EVAPORATE OVERNIGHT.
>> Tucker: OKAY.
LET'S SAY YOU ARE RIGHT.
YOU MAY VERY WELL BE RIGHT,
YOU OFTEN ARE.
MOSTLY ARE IN FACT, THEN WHO
IS IT?
AGAIN, I DON'T SEE ANYBODY
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT AS OF
TODAY WHO COULD GET THE
BERNIE PEOPLE AND THE
FINANCE COMMUNITY.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHO IT'S
GOING TO BE.
THAT'S WHY WE KEEP COMING
BACK.
RIGHT IN THE DEMOCRATS WILL
HAVE TO FIGURE IT OUT.
IT'S PRETTY INTERESTING.
LOOK, AMERICA USUALLY GIVES
ITS PRESIDENTS A SECOND
TERM.
ONLY TWICE SINCE WORLD WAR
II HAS THAT NOT HAPPENED.
ESPECIALLY WHETHER YOU HAVE
AN ECONOMY LIKE THIS THE
NUMBERS YOU WERE SHOWING
WITH LARRY ELDER.
IT'S GOING TO BE FIGHT.
WHEN YOU HAVE THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE STACKING UP THE WAY
IT IS AND PRESIDENT TRUMP
ALREADY DOWN THERE IN
FLORIDA RUNNING AWAY WITH
THE SHOW, IT'S GOING TO BE
VERY HARD FOR DEMOCRATS.
BUT THEY WILL COME UP WITH
SOMEBODY.
>> Tucker: THE LEFT NEEDS TO
CALM DOWN.
THAT COULD HAPPEN AND WE
CAN'T -- DO YOU KNOW WHAT I
MEAN?